[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily i
didn't intend to kill them i intended to
i intended to stop the people who were
attacking me a self-defense law gets
backing from multiple states named after
recently acquitted kyle rittenhouse and
the betrayal of anne frank it was what
would be my longest investigation of my
career hear from the retired fbi
investigator who may have cracked the
case plus the courtroom gets heated as
theodore edgecombe stands trial for
murder your paralegal stays out
she's now a potential witness on two
times she's out for the rest of the
trial but first the fbi gives a final
update into the death of gabby potito
investigation what messages inside brian
laundry's notebook revealed law on crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin five months after gabby petito's
story captivated the nation the fbi
announces brian laundry is the only
person responsible for her death on
friday the fbi released its final update
on the investigation saying messages
inside brian laundry's notebook reveal
he is responsible for petito's death
the notebook was recovered in october
near laundry's partial remains
investigators discovered the remains at
the carleton reserve in florida more
than a month after he went missing
officials confirmed laundry died by
suicide the remains of gabby potato were
discovered a month earlier near grand
teton national park in wyoming officials
determined her cause of death to be
strangulation
this came weeks after patina was
reported missing following a nationwide
road trip she took with fiance brian
laundry in a statement released on
friday the fbi in denver said in part
quote all logical investigative steps
have been concluded in this case the
investigation did not identify any other
individuals other than brian laundry
directly involved in the tragic death of
gabby petito
we're joined today by law and crime
legal analyst dina dahl and co-host
terry austin deena does this mean brian
laundry's parents will not face charges
and is there any other sort of
resolution we could see here
it doesn't appear that they'll be facing
charges i mean for one they now know who
actually killed her and it was their son
it's possible that they committed some
things like obstruction of justice
that's unclear too based on what we know
even if they did though i think it's
unlikely that they would bring any
charges with the case so closed as it is
there it is possible that gabby's family
could file civil lawsuits i mean they
would have a wrongful claim against the
son which with him passed away and no
it's unknown whether or not he has any
assets they can go toward it's also
possible that they could sue the parents
for an intentional infliction of
emotional distress whether or not they
can prove that would be difficult but
it's less of a burden than any kind of a
criminal prosecution against the parent
absolutely possibilities but somewhat
speculative we'll have to see if more
information comes up terry there are
still a lot of unanswered questions in
this case do you think investigators
will ever release what was written in
brian laundry's notebook
well hopefully one day we will have the
opportunity to see what is in that
notebook dina mentioned the fact that
even though there are no criminal
charges which could be brought against
brian laundry's family i definitely
think that some civil charges could be
brought the wrongful death might be a
little bit difficult because there's no
evidence at least according to the
authorities that the parents were
involved with the death but i do think
that intentional infliction of emotional
distress that's not the first time i've
mentioned that could be brought and so i
think get that discovery get the
depositions see what's in that notebook
i think for peace of mind of the parents
and of the public in general all right
we'll see what the facts and the
lawsuits lead us in this case this may
not be the last time we hear the name
gabby petito or brian laundry thank you
both this week on prime crime a story
people are still talking about nearly
two decades later host jesse weber
delves into the scott peterson case he
joins us now with a look ahead jesse
hey there brian on our next episode we
cover the big one the case that arguably
started it all in true crime i'm talking
scott peterson this is the california
man who went on trial for the murder of
his pregnant wife lacy and their unborn
son connor now the nation was captivated
by all aspects of this case including
the way that peterson behaved and what
he said in his infamous police
interrogation tape
he's been married four years
four or five
i didn't make much of the tape scott was
calm in control keep in mind he never
confesses to anything um he gives
his version of events but this case
isn't over there are developments
happening even to this day tune in to
law and crime
thanks jesse you can catch this week's
episode of prime crime friday night at 5
30 p.m and 10 30 pm eastern time here on
lawn crime network
still ahead on law and crime daily
eyewitness testimony as the victim's
wife takes the stand in the theodore
edgecombe trial evangelina claremont
tells the story of what she saw the day
her husband was murdered
but first a cold case may be solved we
sat down with retired fbi agent vince
pankau he shares how he might have
solved the mystery of anne frank's
discovery and betrayal
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live lawn
crime network with youtube tv for all of
your daily live trial coverage legal
news expert analysis and original true
crime programs subscribe to youtube tv
today and then locate law and crime in
the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
welcome back a retired fbi agent who led
a team of cold case investigators in
trying to figure out who turned in anne
frank to the nazis says there could be
more to come long crimes anget levy
spoke with vince pancoak about how the
new book detailing the years-long
investigation began
brian this is one of the 20th century's
most enduring mysteries how did the
nazis find out about the hiding place of
anne frank and four other jews along
with anne frank's family the book the
betrayal of anne frank was released
earlier this week days after a 60-minute
story detailed the work of vince pancoak
and the team of investigators they used
artificial intelligence to sift through
thousands of documents and came upon an
anonymous note sent to anne frank's
father which said a jewish lawyer named
arnold vandenberg was the one who tipped
off the nazis to the address vandenberg
was a member of the jewish council
tasked with implementing nazi policies
many people have been suspected in
telling where the address was over the
years but pancoat and his team believe
that vandenberg is a likely suspect
what is the reaction that you've
received so far
to this information about who you
suspect turned in anne frank and their
family
well the reaction is overwhelmingly
positive so many people were wanting to
read the book they saw the 60 minutes
piece
we did have a few detractors which we
suspected right away who we don't even
think have read the book yet
and but we're hoping to get the message
out um that people can understand the
theory
we're not the first to break this theory
though um this information was out there
and like in a lot of cold cases we
came across it and just wondered why
nobody ever followed up on it in the
past do you think there's more work to
be done on this uh more follow-up after
the book is released and people maybe
read it and will there be more to come
we've already received uh messages from
people that they might have more
information we always have likened this
to
this giant puzzle that ai even was
brought in to help us try to keep it
organized and sort through all the
pieces
we say that the puzzle is showing us a
clear picture now but there are still
missing pieces of the puzzle and we hope
that with some of the information that
comes in it can fill in those missing
pieces
so the message there really is stay
tuned to see what else they are able to
come up with now pancoak says he and his
team have not yet met that beyond a
reasonable doubt threshold and he said
you know they really didn't intend to
this is simply what they came up with
over that nearly six years of
investigation brian
thanks angenet let's bring back legal
analyst dina dahl and terry austin as we
dig into the facts of anne frank's
betrayal terry as new facts are added to
the inquiry of anne frank's death where
do you think the investigation needs to
go next
brian you know this is a very important
historical case it really is like a cold
case so every single lead needs to be
pursued i think the next step is more
forensic technology it can uncover even
more details and even more leads i think
they should be looking at every single
written document they should trace
ancestral records they should interview
obviously anyone who's still alive at
this time any live witness i think can
lead to other information and one of the
things i mentioned before we talked
about this is the purpose of all of this
is not just for the sake of doing it but
for the reason that you don't want this
to be repeated we need to learn from my
history
dean of the circumstances surrounding
the death of anne frank have always been
circumstantial now does this new
information uh give us more questions
than answers or the other way around
about this historic case
you know in terms of her court law kind
of like anjanette was saying you know
they're not intending to prove this
beyond a reasonable doubt if we were
discussing one of our live trials and
there was an anonymous note you know we
would say sure that's a piece of
evidence but is that enough to convict
somebody no so we're talking a little
bit like that here interestingly anne
frank's father knew about this note
years before but he chose to never speak
about it because he didn't know if it
was true and he didn't want to so damage
the reputation of the person because he
has children so obviously this book is
doing a deeper dive this note obviously
has some effect but does it prove that
it is this person again in the court of
law i don't think it would be enough
more digging needs to be done anjanet if
vandenberg is the person who turned over
the address why does pancake believe he
would have turned over other or turned
on sorry on other jewish people
well you know it was a difficult time i
mean people were being sent off in
trains to auschwitz and other
concentration camps on a daily basis and
jews knew what was going on in the very
beginning they may not have known but
but words got out and people understood
that this was basically the nazis final
solution to eliminate jews so they
believed basically that people were in
terrible positions and they were
probably turning on one another in order
to save themselves and their families so
it was just an awful uh thing that was
going on and vince pankow and his team
want people to really think about what
that would have been like to be put in
such a position yeah absolutely it's a
devastating time you bring up auschwitz
actually has visited the internment
camps in auschwitz um it's a complete
tragedy something i think everyone
should be reminded of as terry said a
history we do not want to repeat thank
you all coming up on law and crime daily
a 19 year old setting the precedent for
a possible new law how the calvary in
house of verdict could impact cases in
the future as lawmakers propose a bill
with his namesake
plus a blow-up in wisconsin when the
judge in the theodore edgecombe murder
trial throws a paralegal out of the
court
[Music]
welcome back first-hand testimony on
friday as the victim's wife takes the
stand in the murder trial of theodore
edgecombe in wisconsin but the highlight
of the morning the judge kicking out the
defense team's paralegal just before
cross-examination as a second incident
makes her a potential witness take a
listen
first of all council start by
identifying them
yonder it is the screenshot of miss
jason mr jason we got these screenshots
it's publicly available online tell me
who got the screenshots we got the
screenshots who
stopped saying we
who the defense console uh the paralegal
ashley just printed them out just a
couple minutes ashley who
then again ashley is a witness in this
case
step out
for the rest of this trial
the defense team was trying to introduce
screenshots of the victim's facebook
page claiming his wife's testimony
opened the door to speak on his
character after she said he was peaceful
in testimony thursday there was conflict
with the same paralegal after witness
said the paralegal told him she was a
police officer
edgecombe is charged with the shooting
death of jason clearman when the two got
into an altercation on the road back in
2020. prosecutors say edgecombe was on a
bicycle when he punched clearman a
passenger in a car through an open
window clearman's wife evangelina was
driving at the time
video shows the couple followed edgecomb
onto a bridge as he rode away clearman
got out of the car that's when edgecombe
shot him edgecon was arrested six months
later in kentucky he's claiming it was
self-defense on friday prosecutors asked
evangelina about the interaction her
husband had with edgcomb
the bis this man on the bike came up to
the car to punch him
you know
we didn't do anything i just swerved
around him my husband said what the heck
and then he comes up and he punches my
husband so all this is happening
i'm thinking
why did this happen
so as my husband is approaching the
bicyclist
the bicyclist
and i he's looking at me and looking at
him
he had these really dark cold eyes knew
staring at me
all i saw
was this man's eyes
and the gun
and then i knew he was going to shoot my
husband i could just feel it
and then he pulled the trigger
on his head
and then he looked at me
he kept looking at me actually he never
took his eyes off of me
and i felt like he was contemplating and
shooting me next
dina kind of looking ahead at the end of
the trial mrs clearman will likely be
considered an interested witness what
does that mean and how it'll affect her
testimony
i mean clearly she is interested you
know if she was participating in the
event she drove the car that the
defendant is claiming was chasing him so
the jury is going to weigh that she's
not impartial like maybe some other
witnesses are there and essentially a
lot of this is going to come down to
credibility it's not the the first um
altercation evidently that the defense
says where the car swerved and almost
hit him isn't on video you know this
offensive language which he said said
isn't on video a lot of this is he said
she said and even though the defense
isn't saying it that his attorney is and
they're going to weigh all of that to
see who they believe
yeah and to that point of the offensive
language it's going to be interesting
because that offensive language has to
do with race and now we see that
clairman's wife is a woman of color
should be interesting to just throw it
out there terry how do you see miss
clearman as she held up on the stand
especially during cross-examination
well she was clearly nervous even on the
direct examination but on
cross-examination this was really one of
the most tense cross-examinations i've
ever seen very from the start defensive
she didn't want to answer questions she
said i don't understand can you please
repeat it can you please rephrase it and
so it seemed as though she is interested
she definitely wants to give the defense
as difficult a time as possible so we'll
see what happens but he's pulling teeth
at this point yeah pulling teeth would
definitely be a way i would describe it
but it's understandable you have to
understand what this woman went through
she saw her husband uh and her mind
murdered in front of her now the trial
is expected to wrap up on monday make
sure to watch the law and crime network
for more galileo gavel coverage of the
theodore edgecombe murder trial
when we come back the cobrin house case
is still making headlines after its
acquittal last year now several
lawmakers propose a bill to be named
after the 19 year old we'll discuss how
the new law would work if passed
welcome back fresh off the heels of kyle
rainhouse's monumental acquittal
lawmakers in two states have proposed a
bill named after the 19 year old the
proposed bill backed by politicians in
tennessee and oklahoma would be called
kyle's law and would require the state
to reimburse people who have been
acquitted by self-defense that includes
things like legal fees or wages lost
because of the ongoing litigation this
week dan abrams host of dan abrams live
and founder of the law and crime network
spoke with tennessee state
representative bruce griffey who wrote
the bill and a proclamation to honor
rittenhouse as a hero
anyone who's acquitted can make those
exact same arguments and the people who
are going to be supporting you on that
are going to be
criminal defense attorneys around the
country who i'm guessing you probably
don't agree with on a lot of issues
well and look i trust the jury system
and if you have a jury unanimously come
back and say this prosecution should
never have taken place that's what i
that's the situation i think a defendant
should be entitled to get some
compensation from the state if the jury
because you know there's a difference
between proof beyond a reasonable doubt
and then you know just by proposing
you know they could find a defendant
beyond a reasonable doubt for a number
of reasons the state just did not get
there that doesn't mean a defendant
isn't you know might have violated the
law and doesn't deserve compensation but
if you give the jury the ability to
consider the case and say should this
prosecution have ever taken place and we
have been brought in here to court and
waste our time on this case and the jury
comes back and says no i think that's
appropriate case for the court in the
state to step in and go
you should be compensated for how you
were treated
i mean to your point dan here's one
public defender who support that in new
york
dina washington state has a lot like
this on the books can you explain how
this law would work if implemented in
tennessee and oklahoma
i mean essentially any uh anybody could
already sue for malicious prosecution
and
if they win get damages regardless of
this law but what the washington state
law and other bills do is make it easier
in the same trial as the acquittal the
jury the same jury would decide whether
or not they would be entitled to damage
it so they won't have to bring a
separate lawsuit and what it means is
that if like the um
legislator was saying there
if they cannot say that beyond a
reasonable doubt
he did it but he probably
did it then they wouldn't have to pay
out damages but if they couldn't prove
that he probably did it without
self-defense then he would so it's the
difference between a civil standard
which is the predominance of evidence
and beyond a reasonable doubt which is
the criminal they're conflating the two
into the one trial essentially
yeah terry in listening to
representative griffey i couldn't really
make heads a tale as to why this law was
needed uh when it's or when there's
already a legal recourse for prosecutor
misconduct it made it seem like this was
more him trying to attach his name to
kyle rain house than create a new law um
did you understand why this was
happening
well i guess as dina was saying to make
it easier but i think we already have an
action for malicious prosecution and you
can do that in a civil case or a
criminal case and i don't think you need
to have a separate law to do that so i
think the damages would be the same
absolutely we'll see how it plays out
well thank you for joining us here on
law and crime daily we'll see you next
time as we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you